ألقِ نظرة على الضفدع الوحشي الذي تم العثور عليه في
أستراليا والذي قد يكون حطامًا للأرقام
القياسية العالمية لحراس حديقة هوبر
في متنزه كونواي الوطني يقولون إنهم
لاهثوا عندما اكتشفوا هذا
الضفدع الضخم من القصب قبالة ممر المنتزه الذي قالت إحدى الحراس
إنها لا تصدق  مدى ثقل
البرمائيات في ما
يقرب من ستة أرطال من مقاطع الفيديو المشتركة وصور
اكتشاف التثبيت والتثبيت
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي حصلت على مجموعة واسعة من
ردود الفعل وعززت الاسم المستعار
toadzilla Rangers الذي سحب تيتانيك
بعيدًا مشيرًا إليه باعتباره تهديدًا غازيًا.
يقول أن toadzilla يمكن أن يحطم
الرقم القياسي العالمي لموسوعة جينيس لأكبر ضفدع ، وهو
لقب تم الاحتفاظ به منذ عام 1991.
بالحديث عن محاولات الرقم القياسي العالمي ، ألقِ
نظرة على واحد لا يمكن وصفه إلا بالتاريخ
الجبن في الخبز الحقيقي لعمل
بيتزا
وهكذا دواليك بيتزا هت  صنع
منافسًا ضخمًا لأكبر
بيتزا في العالم ، فطيرة مترامية الأطراف
تغطي أكثر من أربعة عشر ألف
قدم مربع من أرضية مركز المؤتمرات في لوس أنجلوس بصلصة
العجين والجبن ، كانت
كبيرة جدًا لدرجة أنه كان يتعين عليهم خبزها في أقسام
على مدار عدة ساعات باستخدام
جهاز الفرن الذي يحوم بتقنية عالية ،
أنتج Crusty Contender 68000 شريحة
وتبرع بها الكوخ لاحقًا
لعدة جمعيات خيرية الآن يلعبون
لعبة الانتظار لمعرفة ما إذا كان
مشروع البيتزا الرائع هذا يقدم أربعة ألق نظرة
على هذا أنا جيريمي روث